The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So here's some code.
I'm defining a
function named sq,
and it takes in two parameters.
I'm defining a function named
f, takes in one parameter,
and then I'm doing
these two lines.
The first one is just
calling function sq,
and the next one is
just printing the value.
So let's first see what-- nice.
OK.
Let's work through it.
So The first things we see here
is two function definitions,
right?
So we don't currently
care about what's
inside them right now because
we haven't made a function
call yet.
So the first thing we do
is we have the function
call calc equal sq f and 2.
OK?
So inside sq, we're
going to have func and x.
And func is going
to get mapped to f,
and x is going to get
mapped to 2, right?
So we're taking the
variables in order
and mapping them to those.
Func is f, and x is 2.
First thing the
function does, sq,
is create this variable
y is equal to x squared.
So we're going to
have y is equal to 4.
And then we're going
to return func y.
So func of y, this is
going to be-- we're
just replacing the
parameters f of 4, right?
So now this is
another function call.
We know what f is.
This program knows what f is.
f is going to be this part right
here, which returns x squared.
OK?
So in f, x gets mapped to
whatever variable we put in,
which in this case is 4.
And we're going to
return to whoever
called us, which is over
here, 4 squared, which is 16.
OK?
So f of 4 gets replaced with 16.
And f of 4 was up here, right?
We're just popping
out of scopes now.
So f of 4 was up here.
So then that line there, return
func y, is going to return 16.
And whoever called us was down
here, calc is equal to 16.
And then we're
just printing calc.
So 16 was right.
Yay.